so you don't think that that humanity is
10,000 years old but you think that view
is more insightful to quote CS Le no
don't quote what quote yourself to quote
Michael NS to quote Michael NS Earth to
quote Michael NES one time I read CS
Lewis and what he told me no I'm quoting
me the human species is blank years old
roughly 10 so you think so yes is the
answer no
no
[Music]
it's been a long time since we filmed
what became the most popular episode of
this show and so I decided it's time for
a rematch even though I don't remember
who won first though the greatest
interview show that is also the greatest
party game also happens to be the
greatest gift to give this holiday
season better yet it's on sale right now
for Black Friday the yes or no game and
conspiracy expansion pack bundle is 35%
off right now but only for Black Friday
this is the best deal ever offered for
yes or no the original game is great the
conspiracy pack not only has great
questions for your parties we will get
to some of those questions in this very
show so go get yours today dailywire.com
shop I cannot believe how discounted
these are in fact I hate it because it's
going to cut into my Pro but that's okay
I don't make these
decisions we have sold out instantly
more times than I can count and I cannot
imagine that we will last very long with
a deal like this so do not wait makes
the perfect stocking stuffer and U tide
Gathering activity go to dailywire.com
shop to get yours while this deal and
supplies last Mr
Walsh I don't know who won the last game
I don't remember that this ever happened
yeah well part of that I think is Cheer
y Chin Chin to your health yep you
remember the rules I don't that makes
two of us but I am supposed to wait to
drink until something happens yes you if
you get it right then you get to drink
and if you get it wrong you have to
drink got it okay I will go
first most lesbians can't do three
push-ups and shouldn't should not serve
in combat role
wait what am I I'm guessing whether you
think that's correct yes and then you'll
move my glass based on what you think my
answer would be so most
lesbians can't do three push-ups and
should not serve in combat roles uh I
think that's obviously
yes it's the and that's getting is it
all right well you said it's obviously a
yes so I I agree that that's your answer
I just it's an ant I think probably most
lesbians could do three push-ups they
shouldn't serve in combat roles but do
you think most women can do three
push-ups I don't know but I bet that
lesbians outperform women generally what
is it about being a lesbian that would
you with upper body strike they're
really they're really yeah I guess I I
mean here's well if that's correct I
would say maybe women on average can do
no push-ups yeah and lesbians on average
can do like one and a half okay but it's
not three and we're we're basically
taking the lipstick lesbians out of this
also because they don't exist right yeah
but are we talking about lesbians in
combat roles or women in general I think
lesbians does that change your answer
because I'm opposed to women in combat
right are you saying we can make an
exception for lesbians no no I think I
think yeah I don't know why we focus
this on lesbians yeah I yeah why is Mr
Davies so focused on lesbians it's a
really good question all right Europe oh
okay
um Matt Walsh takes more vacation days
than Joe
Biden it's it's
unfair that you get so many vacation
days it's it's un well first of all
because no like if I take two vacation
days in in a whole year then I take more
vacation than any like you don't you
don't go on vacation I basically don't
go on vacation do you know why I'm going
to tell you
maybe this is a a Neurosis of mine I
have this fear that if I miss even one
minute of my show yeah people they're
going to say wait I don't need to listen
to that why do I need to listen to that
guy and they'll never listen to me again
but here's the point the audience
already knows that like they know they
don't need us so you think they were
they're pulling this over on them but
they already aware of it so you might as
well just go on vacation enjoy yourself
and I didn't I think it was an obvious
answer I I'm saying this about
myself I'm saying what do you think
you're saying what I think but I now I
said that you would agree because you're
a reasonable man uh you know you say no
yeah no I say no wow now I have to I
take I take like one vacation a year you
take at most One Vacation a day at most
at most I'm and most weeks it's only two
vacations a week and I get killed the
audience kills me over yeah like I'm not
allowed to leave where do you
go places I don't know like you know
have uh sometimes the family disagrees
and they think like it's nice to see
everyone once a while I guess that's the
difference because I I say to Alisa I'll
say hey girl you you want to you know I
think today I think this year I'm going
to take a few days vacation Ma you gotta
work you gotta work Ma I see you too
much I'll say well I I see you like an
hour a day that's enough ma go on get
get that's what I that's what I get
that's the life I don't I do not take
more vacation days of Joe yeah okay take
at least one last day one last minute
yeah worrying about ozone depletion and
acid rain is basic liberal white girl
Behavior the hysteria is basically just
a scheme to get grant money from the
government uh see here's the the issue
is there are two claims being made here
wait do you explain your thoughts on it
before I you're right okay let's move
let's move I just don't know I don't
even know I don't even know my own
thoughts right I'm going to say yes I
mean obviously why why was that why is
that think I'm I'm gonna have to say no
actually because yes it's basic white
girl Behavior obviously yeah I don't
think it's just about getting grants
from the government I I think the the
more Marxist analysis of all these
programs is that it's all just about the
money but I don't think it's just about
the money I think it's about controlling
us I think it's about deadening our
Spirits I think it's about taking away
our controlling us as part of I don't
remember oh grant money from the Govern
government yeah yeah all right so do I
get a point well I'm changing can I
change my answer I'm changing mine wait
you can't change your answer said was
right just I didn't realize the just I
didn't hear the just part all right
judges judges does this man get to cheat
like this and change his answer the just
changes everything I didn't hear can I
get an official ruling please he can
change it whose side are you on it's
what I
believe okay okay I'm going to drink
anyway all
right condoms are at least kind of
[Music]
gay but they added in the at least there
so I don't even know how does that
impact so they could be super gay or at
least but they're at least kind of gay
why do you need at least if kind of is
already there is my question yeah is it
there could be adjus in a basically
there a lot of weasy modifiers condoms
are at least just basically kind of get
kind of super um yeah well you've
already I think you're you've Media
Matters has documented your I I'm not
joking this I I retweeted the Media
Matters clip of me saying
that like 25 minutes ago before I came
to this studio the the the writers of
this would not have even seen that
because thanks birth control yeah I saw
that did you see that but it is it is
gay there's nothing if a conservative is
going anyone who has a traditional
sexual ethic is going
to U disagree with the sexual Revolution
and the LGBT element of then I think
he's got to be consistent because what's
wrong with the LGBT one of the main
things that's wrong with the LGBT stuff
is that it's a it's a sterile sexual
ethic but so is birth control so it's
it's at least kind of gay right yeah
you've got what now 17 kids yeah well
that's why I think that my with six kids
my my opinion on that probably pretty
well
established although we are doing two at
a time so it's true that that's kind of
cheating but you are you are not kind of
gay you are I appreciate that you are
not the numbers there if you had only
had like four or four and a half I would
say well jury's out but six you got
catching up to do I got some catching up
to do I got some proven to do I already
in my intro and my show I'm dancing in
loafers so I might need eight actually
to prove it that's a whole other
conversation yeah maybe maybe later in
the cars dancing on the desk yeah do you
know why what was the thought process
there so first of all I didn't write
that part that was some of our Ecentric
Michael's intro is at least kind of gay
it's at least kind of but then I I kind
of liked it because here my thought was
Media Matters it's kind of gay but I
kind of like it but I kind of liked it
because I'm pretty and witty and the
Media Matters they're always trying to
say nolles is a homophobe he he's going
to like throw gay guys off rooftops like
the Taliban or whatever and I thought a
great way to counteract that is in the
show I can have my really traditional
rhetoric right and I have the gayest
intro but if I have gayest intro of of
not just any conservative talk show of
any show yeah ever including queer ey
for the stra ey if I have that it's
going to balance out and kind of trick
them that's my theory at least it Al is
how's the audience feel about the intro
they they are so torn on it some the
ones who really get it the sort of
straussian esoteric viewers they they
get a kick out of but I would say your
average kind of conservative guy looks
at that and he says uh Michael you look
like a pho and I can't dispute that it's
a That's Italian for fenel I think
actually but it but the meaning is
you're a little uh you know to me it has
friend of dthy a Wes Anderson vibe to it
yes it does I don't mean that as a
compliment now W Anderson is at least
kind kind of gay letting your wife Drive
is the most egregious form of vehicular
cuckle I hadn't heard that
yet I'm going to
say Obviously it is yes I certain I mean
if it it becomes more of a dispute if
it's like the most egregious form of
cuckle Dre yeah no that would be when
the mailman enters your house there
there's a lot of EG yeah but vehicular
like what other ve you know how many
times how many ways can you cuckold
yourself in a car I right especially a
moving car I guess if the mailman is
asking for a ride yeah but well yeah I
thought before I finished reading the
question I thought it was going to say
it's the most egregious form of
vehicular risk taking or danger or
recklessness in which case I I would say
it's not the most D it's proba if you
had if you went out and had 10 shots of
vodka smoked a couple crack pipes and
and got behind the wheel of a car that
would at least be on par with I my crack
pipes pretty well tolerance so I I I was
one time driving around with a daily
wire host in the middle of Texas and his
wife not going to say but his wife drove
because we had had a few coca-colas and
this daily wire host I'm not going to
say who he said okay I think that it's
less dangerous for my wife sober to
drive than it is for me drunk to drive
but the jury's at which host was that so
it's a male it's a male I'm not going to
say who you probably weren't driving
around with Ben so no I think I wouldn't
and Ben he doesn't drink a lot rarita
every yeah true I you know I um yeah I I
I think it's well here's the thing I
think it's shame full to allow your wife
to drive I I will admit that on we do a
lot of driving in my yeah family we
drive like 18 hours so in our most
recent 18- hour
trip I did surrender the wheel for I'd
say two of the 18 hours it's still 16 of
18 hours were you sleeping during that
or you were just kind of hanging out
well I was I wanted to sleep but then I
couldn't because I was so terrified she
was going to kill us so I st but then
this is true like two of 16 hours is all
and we happened to pull into a uh a uh
rest stop and some you know I got
recognized sitting in the freaking car
like a a fan pulled up right next to us
and parked you're most recognizable in a
car that is kind of your your home
setting as soon as we pulled in and I'm
in the passenger seat I actually thought
to myself like this would be really
embarrassing if someone knows me and
right in that moment seriously someone
pulled in parked got out of their car
hey it's Matt Walsh sitting in the
passenger seat how did you live that
down I didn't you didn't yeah that's not
possible can't do it you're
up
um fractured memories can be passed
through your
DNA I'm going to I I don't even know
what that means yeah I don't really know
either fractured memories it sounds like
bullsh but it
sounds is that like is it just like
racism is it just like you
inherit the you know op no it's your
memories it's like so you have memories
of your past of of your
descendants I'm gonna have to say no I
don't even know where that comes from
why would that why was this why was that
in who wrote that I don't know fractured
me like epigenetics is real that's not
Memories that's not a memory like like
you're sleeping you have a flashback to
getting chased by a saber-tooth tiger or
something I think is what it means I wow
I don't have many of those flashbacks
yeah me very rarely yeah I mean a little
bit a few acid trips in India occasional
but not not the
saber okay
on life well speaking of Life as we know
it started about 8,000 years ago and all
the 24 billion years old nonsense is
just a bunch of Lies cooked up by
atheists liberals and other assorted
hippies
uh that's interesting I'm glad that
one's in there cuz I actually don't
know if you're one of these young
Earth I don't know if you're in the
kenam camp or not I more I'm more of a
Ken Pudo kind of gu
true say yes I'm I'm going to say that
you are I have a tough answer on this of
course you do but to to get the point at
least I'm going to say no but here's my
view which really could fall into either
category I do not have any strong
theological not not a strong theological
need or anthropological or historical
need to say that the Earth is 8,000 let
me just clarify one thing I thought I
didn't think you had a theological
reason to to say that the Earth is 8,000
years old I figured it contrari purely
contr I thought that's that's what would
lead you there no it I guess this is my
issue I like the contrarian part is nice
too the issue
is one the 24 billion years stuff they
change that number all the time and
they'll say the universe is actually
half as old as they said it was or twice
as old or whatever so that they don't
really know but I don't
need uh the first chapters of Genesis to
be read literally and in fact I think
it's a bit odd to read them literally
but if I am convinced that the
description of the evolution of mankind
as given in the Book of Genesis right is
more
accurate than whatever gobble deie so do
you think the Earth you don't need the
Earth to be very young but do you think
that it is that was the question I don't
think the Earth is very
young if if
mankind I don't know how old mankind is
I'm not convinced by any of the numbers
that are thrown around and I what I am
convinced of is that
the view of human history as being six
or 10,000 years is a a
more uh insightful view than whatever
it's like 200,000 years and we used to
be like cavemen beating each other on
the heads or whatever so I but I so you
don't think that that humanity is 10,000
years old but you think that view is
more insightful no I'm saying that it is
10,000 years old is more insightful than
it but you don't think that it is or you
do
to quote CS Lewis no don't quote what
quote yourself okay to quote Michael NES
to quote Michael NS Earth to quote
Michael NES one time I read CS Lewis and
what he told me no I'm quoting me the
Earth is blank years old the earth oh I
don't know the Earth can be a bazillion
years old I don't care about the human
species is blank years old the human
species fill in the blank for all
intents and purposes no no I just say
yes do you mean for all intents and
purpos because if
it's if some kind of evolution took
place whether that is uh punctuated
equilibrium whether that is a kind of
minor type of evolution if some kind of
evolution if there were some breeding
between a group that we now call
question some well but the reason what
matters is this to to quote CS leis if
there was some kind of aplike human-like
creature and Life as we know it that's
not even human life life as we meaning
like mitochondrial you know existence
like everything around
you well everything around me is rather
young if you're saying like rocks and
stuff I don't know very young I mean the
ground yeah the ground is it's old you
don't have to dig that right yeah the
ground is old but but Life as we know it
meaning human
beings
uh how old do you think the human
species
is not counting like you know caveman or
Nephilim or anything just
human I
think anything we would describe as is
human roughly 10,000 years old so you
think so yes is the answer no I would
say we got all around this circle the
purposes of my point no because listen I
I iy it took you 24 billion years to
answer the question we got back to
there's there's something like there's
probably something like a neanderthal in
fact if you look at the the mixtures of
of uh
DNA subsaharan Africans don't have any
Neanderthal in them people who come not
from South Subs Africa do have
Neanderthal there different breakdowns
in like Aboriginal Australians and all
this kind of stuff so like there were
weird like vaguely gorilla-like
creatures who were bordering on uh
humans I think neanderthals some of said
buried their dead what does that mean I
don't know what any of that means I
don't know what all of this is about but
if you're asking me about something that
we would call I'm not asking anything
I'm asking with the card you ask
yourself look the card is very ambiguous
it's it's not ambiguous at all really
know it life what is like Life as we
know it or life what are you are you a
lib now you don't know what life is no
I'm saying are we talking about a
procaryotic cell or are we talking about
a tic cell are we talking about light
the ex talking about a virus that's not
even life then whatever you consider
life to be well now we're getting real
hippie man whatever it's like man your
life is you know okay but so your answer
is yes is what my answer judges in that
in my beautifully articulate description
of of reconciling the literal and the
figurative where do you rule is my did I
say no or
yes I said no that's cuz Davies is like
a younger guy but Davies said that
because he thinks the Earth is like
three days old he goes even further you
know he doesn't he doesn't believe in
the
1950s uh as far as the so so uh as far
as the Earth itself or really the
universe to me
yeah I'm the last guy to say trust the
science because we know where that leads
this is all fake right however
um there there are some inescapable
physical realities so for example
there's like the the distant what the
young Earth Creations would call the the
distant Starlight problem a problem to
me it's not a problem but but when
you're looking up at the sky and you can
see a star yeah yeah that's a that's a
million light years away that means that
like that's proof right there that the
Earth has been around or rather the
universe has been around for at least
and this this is not a problem for
Catholics in in part because the
theorizer of the big was a not only a
Catholic but a Catholic priest father
George lametra so that doesn't bother me
whatsoever um though they do kind of
change the numbers on how old things are
and you know they're kind of interesting
it's not going to be exact but I think
we know the universe is very very old
but I guess where it where the rubber
really meets the road for me is not it's
not even the age of the human race which
it can be whatever do we descend from
common ancestors Adam and Eve that's
where the rubber meets the road can be
where I I think yes well right but I
think you also touched on it that as
Catholics the great thing is that none
of this is like a problem monogenism is
though we Pas the 12 said that we have
to believe in a common ancestor yeah so
are you you're not okay I don't know if
you if you became a Protestant on this
episode that would be big ratings well
but Protestants but but young Earth
creationist is
is aliens are just a cooked up narrative
by modernists trying to cover up the
metaphysical reality of angels and
people they not challenging us too much
on this one
MH yeah and you're going to say I'm just
trying to see if you've come to your
senses
yet I'm going to drink it either way so
I'll just take it the alien question is
related to the previous
question I don't think it is why is it
related because how are they
saved well I don't know what their
salvation history is is there a fourth
person of the Trinity no who's like a
martian no no no so but you're the one
just quoting CS Lewis a second ago we
know C that's gets me into trouble I
know so you know we don't know I I can't
that's an that's a question I can't
answer but just because I can't answer
the question doesn't mean that like just
because it's incomprehensible for me
like what would the Salvation history be
of a of a intell would they even be
fallen yeah would they it's I think it's
I think at a minimum it would seem to me
that any rational species in the
universe would have had the same
opportunity to make a choice as we
did um and if it's a real Choice then
you could have unfallen species yeah I
don't see why although I don't even onto
that like a little baby doesn't have the
choice the little baby's born into
original sin so is it the case like
Milton describes in Paradise Lost yeah
but the or the actual original sin comes
from the human beings right so but it
pervades all of creation you know like
it pervades the deer and the trees and
the whole thing right sin and death
pervade the whole Cosmos but I think
it's I think it's clear that scripture
is talking about scripture has no
interest in the universe there's very
little the cosmos there's very little
about it and what is said is like if you
take it literally you come to some
incorrect conclusions about the nature
of the cosmos which tells me that it's
just not the Bible's not trying to tell
us anything about the rest of the
universe one way or another probably
because it's
not something we need to know look this
is what Cardinal Bron he said the Bible
tells us how to go to heaven not how the
heavens go there a little bit lib
because there was kind of like for pro
Galileo which is a whole
other mess but I do know how the have to
go yeah and they go with ET in general
dating sites are for guys who don't have
the gun to talk to a woman in
person he wrote a nastier word there but
I put it in Italian what are you
write that's a word for
kones gulun what did he write balls you
know he wrote yeah why is balls nastier
why is balls nastier than what you said
because no one speaks Italian the ball
is like a one syllable word I think it's
a fine word yeah but Italian is so
beautiful you know that sounds almost
romantic he Kima what
that so you think Italian balls are
beautiful that's that's almost a direct
translation I don't even remember the
question we were talking about gulun so
much there for guys who' uh uh I'm gonna
say you said no to that right yeah
that's correct I'm correct no you're
correct about my
guess you're trying to Intuit it the
answer by like staring at me yeah
uh yeah no that's correct okay no I
don't think look uh
uh I what's that it's 2023 dating sites
are can be a really useful tool if I
mean first of all I try not to I cannot
imagine being in the modern dating scene
it just must be a nightmare like I thank
God every day I'm not in it so I don't
want to sit here as a May happily
married man and say well you shouldn't
be using that tool yeah um and probably
if you want to meet someone these days
like there's it's just it's it's
probably one of the only ways to do it
yeah and going up and talking to someone
randomly is Rife
with difficulty right and especially
today I I back in my single days brief
though they were you know what I like
women I liked chatting women up and
asking them out that's not I don't find
that to be I find that kind of fun
but today we're in the me too culture
yeah so you go up to a woman you say hi
you know I like your dress and she like
bear sprays you you know and has you
arrested or something you can't do that
yeah I mean the dating you know and all
not all sites are made the same so yeah
the hookup apps are one thing I think
they still have like you Harmony oh yeah
my parents met on grinder I you know did
they yeah yeah classic classic love
classic you know tail is old as time I
have friends who are black or my
producer is black should be accepted as
an argument against accusations of
racism
I've been saying that about Davies for
years
[Music]
uh wrong wrong bucko I'm going to
challenge my inner inner uh Jordan
Peterson there I think it's a totally
acceptable yeah excuse I I agree well
here's my my only caveat is I don't
think that you should be offering like
these desperate defenses I'm not racist
because however like when it comes to
actual defenses I've always thought like
having a black friend it's like yeah
that's you're probably not racist if you
have a black friend how is that not
everyone said oh That's a classic That's
a classic racist say if you actually
have a friend who is of that race it's a
pretty good indication you don't hate
people of that race by the way most of
the white Libs don't have black some of
them do I'm not saying none of them have
black friends but a lot of them live in
the most ly white neighborhoods that
exist and then they attack those of us
who have black friends or black
producers yeah me you can't if you have
a Black producer it's imp you can't be
racist it's not possible I know if I was
racist I would have went to the Daily
wire years ago and said I can't work
with this person yeah because I'm racist
I would have said that but I never said
that I actually have said many times
please fire Ben Davies and get me a
Black producer yeah that's how
anti-racist you are that is I know I
said or a white producer or just anybody
other than Ben Davies yeah okay the
recent decline in church attendance is
actually more concerning when accounting
for the number of FBI agents in the
congregation
hadn't thought about that actually
uh you got it right yeah that is Ian
it's concerning in general I guess when
you add in that I had thought I had
thought about it either yeah especially
you consider if you go to a more
traditional church service yeah
certainly the Latin Mass that's got to
be like two-thirds feds at this point
true and it is uh it it's it's a big
it's like you know there's reason to
think that the church like what does it
look like in 20 years
are there church how many churches are
still left right in Germany none in
Germany it's going to be they'll be
either Unitarian or just like I don't
know Cordell or something but it's also
self-inflicted because uh I I still
think the pandemic comes along the
church is willingly shut down lots of
people yeah lot of people weren't going
already but many people who were said
well if apparently it's not that
important you can just shut down and
what do I need you from I even some
Christians told me they said Michael the
church is not a place you know it's the
people it's the called out people and
obviously there's a lot of Truth to that
it's also a place it's also a place it's
like a place where you gather more more
than two together and you have
sacraments and stuff and you don't have
the the right and the sacrament of the
purel and the face Mantia and it's
called a church called a church so we
call it that yeah is it mine uh yes
practically speaking AI porn should at
least be allowed to progress because it
removes at least the objectified part
parties from the equation and puts pimps
out of
business I'd be shocked if you that's
ridicul it's insane you know though why
people think it look we have I won't
name them but we have friends prominent
conservatives who who would say no porn
is fine because you know you can blow
off a little steam and then you're not
going to go to a wh house or or cheat on
your wife or in some other way but I
think the reason especially certain genx
and Boomer conservatives think that I
think because they're in the thrall of
Freud whether they know it or not and
they think that the mind is like a steam
engine and they think you got to just
blow off a little steam you know and so
you're going to go look at your weirdo
AI porn at night and that's then you'll
feel better during the day but like
that's not how it works if you look at
your weirdo porn at night you know what
you're going to do the next day look at
weird weirder porn yeah you're and then
eventually you're going to cheat on your
wife and I think arguably so I think AI
porn
is less harmful to the participants
because they're not real yeah but
arguably it's probably more harmful I
mean you can make an argument it's more
harmful to the viewer just because it's
it's even less human like watching porn
is already a very dehumanizing right
thing to do and uh and now you're
watching these figures who aren't even
people yeah just Phantoms becoming like
sexually aroused by like what's really
just digital code on a screen right
which uh I would argue is if anything is
like more harmful to the it's also more
dangerous one time I was speaking to a
boomer friend and he said I can't
believe these kids you know they'd
rather look at porn than go sleep with a
woman and I said I totally I totally get
it and the reason I get it is because
you go talk to a woman she might reject
you she's not going to be perfect she's
not going to just do every weirdo
fantasy in your head but porn
increasingly with AI you can construct
just your craziest fantasy of a person
that doesn't even exist and so in a way
it's it's really dangerous even to your
own appetite you think that like a
regular porn would mess up Men's views
of sex wait until you can just craft
whatever insanity is banging around your
head and they and they prefer uh porn
because it's they think of sex as
nothing but as you said just a uh
mechanis a release like it's just a a
thing and you get what you want out of
it then you move on and if that's all it
is then yeah porn is a much easier
replacement if you take out the whole
like human relationship part of the
equation we won't be able to put this
part on certain social media platform
[Music]
but it's exact
yeah Western opposition
to the Ugandan law putting restrictions
on weird sex stuff is really just a form
of
neocolonialism Y for sure yeah that's
what what else would you call neoc
Colonials right it's the only form of
colonialism that's still like operative
in the world and I I say that as someone
who's like an an Unapologetic advocate
for many forms of colonialism as I
assume you are as well yeah of course um
but you want it it to kind of it's not
just the process it's not just
colonialism re large it's well what are
you spreading right truth justice the
American way Christianity the faith or
like a rainbow flag in Kandahar yeah
it's really it's really all about
Christianity I mean that's that's that's
why colonialism 500 years ago was
primarily yeah an effort to spread the
faith and now it's an effort to destroy
the faith and so that's why it's right
this is another people misunderstand
Columbus immensely but Columbus is Prime
motivator was the spread of the faith
and and even in as much as he wanted to
find riches it was to fund another
Crusade this man was extremely devout
and because we live in a materialist age
we can't we just don't even understand
that we don't understand what it means
to have a belief in something Beyond
this world and have that motivate your
behavior but that was the whole thing I
mean that led to the founding of the
Western Hemisphere I think the two
biggest Columbus fans in media are
sitting at this table probably the two
only ones so
I have like to Christopher I have one
Columbus rant that I just give every
Columbus Day just I just return to it
yeah and the audience is like bored and
please move on please take vacation uh
okay now we finally got to an
interesting one leaning your seat back
on an airplane is a paying customer's
human right leaning your seat back is a
human right for the paying customer I'm
going to
hope that
you have your wits about you on this
issue and and I in total despair for you
and your reason and
Society I'm going to now realize that
you have fallen into evil and vice
you're a you're a seat lean backer
frankly before takeoff sometimes okay
but hold on a second wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait but you're talking
about first class Mr El I'm talking
about Coach too but yes certainly first
don't pretend you flight coach first of
all I have listen I'll give you a good
example of this when daily wire books My
Flights I I want first class I want to
be sitting you know of course with the
pilots eating vagra yeah but I I when
you book your own you go coach oh yeah
oh because sometimes I get the automatic
upgrade and just recently I went to
visit our friend Jeremy boring and
Jonathan hey international flight you
did Coach I because I was booking my own
and I thought maybe I can work a and I
did you don't want to know the scam I
got so I booked coach I wanted an
upgrade they said okay sir we've
upgraded you to comfort plus that's a
Croc that's not that's nothing that just
means you get a free drink and so then
on the way back I I got a little slight
upgrade not like the full business but I
did a slight upgrade but on the way
there I'm in coach and it was hell it
was hell mat it was International I'm
sorry you went through that it was no
one has suffered as I suffered yeah on
this flight except everybody else but
yeah yeah other than all other people on
the plane and most other people for
human history and I but I you know I
needed that extra two inches no you
wouldn't you would if you were in my
shoes you would not have reclined no
because I'm not a sociopath which is why
we're you stayed awake all night I don't
contemplating your
virtue that's how I spend every day but
uh I don't I don't believe uh I don't
sleep on planes to begin with because I
don't want to sleep it's weird to sleep
I think frankly I think it's like
slightly gay to sleep around some other
strange man yeah yeah and there's many
on that's why I keep I put my loafers on
when I do it that's those are instead of
slippers I Drool on them sometimes it is
gay to sleep on a plane I'm and
adulterous to sleep next to a woman on a
plane exactly so I don't when we I mean
I've been on international flights 18
hours I don't sleep because I'm so
committed to this even so then why would
you buy business class the only reason
to get business just so I have my space
to myself so I could be a human being
treated like a human I I cuddle up I
when especially when I get business I I
kick my little I curl up in a fetal
position I've got I put the sleep mask
on have you been on a flight where they
give you pajamas I no no was that Africa
guitar Airlines to Africa they give you
pajamas and I I got the pajamas I'm like
and I'm like I'm not putting these on
and I look back and our and our like
security guy already has his pamas on so
um no I you don't you don't lean your
flight lean your suit back on flight
because it's the you know because you're
in coach that the person be you have two
you don't have the leg room to spare no
no you can't type on your laptop if the
guy's reclining exactly you can't you
can't you can't do work you can't eat
like the tra they going to give you
they're going to give you a Hot Pocket
in coach they're not you're not getting
okay but you can't use the trade table
for whatever you can't use the trade
table you can't and so you are you are
choosing to take that away from the
person behind you yeah oh yeah and you
deserve to be shot in the
head I love it in fact you know what I'm
going to do the next time I'm going to
recline and then I'm going to take his
hot body could do I'm going reach back
it's going to be delicious I I spoke out
about this I assume it's why it's there
and I just got killed for I was I
honestly was shocked by how wrong and
I'm not usually shocked by this no I was
shocked by how wrong everybody is on
this I and also how how seriously they
people were like legitimately angry at
me for criticizing you know why look I'm
a cheap skate it's not I guess if I
wanted to I guess I could have even
personally bought this expensive
business but I said I'm a cheap skate I
can't do it even the cheap tickets I'm
flying to New York for Thanksgiving yeah
you fly a family of Ford in New York
it's like thousands of dollars so I'm
every inch on my seat that I am paying
for that's I don't know that's like a
$60 inch right by some Med and you're
taking it away from the person behind
you yeah I guess I I had just had this
great Compassion maybe the common man
take too you're a man of the people uh
I'm up
Republican Governors should also include
their home homeless populations in their
shipments of illegal immigrants to
Liberal cities was not a bad idea uh I
shouldn't have given away my answer well
yeah I did you revealed yourself I did
um I guess right yeah I think it's
actually a good idea Rudy did that back
in I think he did that in the 90s in New
York he just shipped them all out yeah
like Jersey or something I mean you got
you got to ship them somewhere we talked
about this on the show recently but like
yeah the homeless people
either they're choosing to be on the
street um because they don't feel like
working in which case yeah vagrancy
should be illegal and we say to them go
get a job this is not a choice you
should be able to make yeah or they're
not choosing it because they can't
function in society mentally right which
is most of them in which case vagrancy
should be illegal and you ship them off
to an institution right because it's not
charitable to let them like die of
exposure right exactly I've walked out
of a Subway and it's really sad walked
out of a Subway there a guy had died a
homeless guy had died of exposure a lot
of if you live in New York or San
Francisco you've probably seen that
before and so that's obviously not
compassionate you give them money you
give homeless money sometimes yeah I I
make it a matter of prudence yeah like I
don't want to kill them I don't want to
give them money that it's just going to
immediately I don't want to k i you know
sometimes that what you think is Charity
could actually like kill those guys yeah
okay I see what you're saying you know
what I'm say but yeah I I was at I was
at the uh uh gas station just last night
and a woman came up to me asking for
money like the whole it's always the
same story about I got to get the bus I
like there's no bus around here what
yeah and she said something we going to
Chicago I'm like you need to go to Chico
I gave her the money because I'm like
yeah I know I'm getting scammed but
there was one time I was driving up to a
bar in LA and I like my wife was out of
town I knew I was going to have a few
drinks with the Fons and so I hadn't had
dinner and I I pulled into a McDonald's
to get a quick dinner before I didn't
want to have drinks if not without
dinner and I'm sitting there just on my
phone or something and this this
homeless woman like knocks on my window
I said ah she goes hey give me money and
I said huh no I'm not giving you any
money you're obviously going to buy a
bunch of drugs and she goes give me
money you know and I said no I said but
I'll buy you some
food she goes and she looked so angry
and she goes okay fine I said okay what
do you want she goes okay I want uh two
fillet of
fish okay and I want eggs that was the
brief period McDonald's was serving
breakfast all day I want eggs and I want
and she picked all these really weird
menu items and she Rings up her tab
probably to like 35 bucks and I said
okay all right that'll get you through
the night that's enough food okay all
right so I go in and I order all this
weird food plus my Double Quarter
Pounder like come out she's gone she's
good she just set she just wanted that's
hilarious yeah and I well done so angry
that I I said she's not going to get the
last laugh so I brought the food home
put it in the fridge and over about 2
days I ate every bite of it
yeah what's your order at Double Quarter
Pand with cheese always that's my go-to
Fridays double fet of fish it's better
than it sounds fet fish is is good it's
good what's McDonald's and breakfast
like no one no fast food chain has
figured out how to do a better breakfast
than McDonald's no one's figured it out
no it's it's what's your move though on
the like a like an evening kind of
McDonald's uh you know usually I go with
the with the Big Mac just plastic but
I'll go filet fish even when it's not a
Friday I just I think I think it's it's
just a good just a good meal that's you
disagree sick that's a psycho order
really like I'll eat it I I was coming
home from I got a FL fish a couple weeks
ago like one o'clock in the morning I
was coming home from you and Trump
Trump's a filet of fish guy is
he the only thing we have in common
birth control and other hormone altering
drugs explain why women have generally
become crazier and more liberal but I
repeat myself over the past half century
uh
uh you're going to say no but you're
wrong I will say yes okay I thought no
because okay I thought you're GNA have
some like well it's not that simple and
then go into some that is my answer is
it's not that simple except in this case
it sort of is the drugs themselves have
driven women crazy and the availability
of the
drugs which spurred the sexual
Revolution have been the driver of
women's craziness over the last half
century which I I don't think that's too
Cy on it would you did I get you right
yeah you got it right because I I just
don't I I actually am going I don't
think it's that simple route because I
also think that the craziness of men has
increased at exactly the same rate and
they're not taking birth control pills
for the most part but why have the men
gone crazy well yeah I mean you could I
just think they're cultural factors it's
it's also part of the moral decay of
which birth control I would argue is a
symptom but not the cause you think
though if so 1965 the Supreme Court says
married couples can use birth control
because in the constitution in invisible
Inc we found the right the right the
special Amendment where you get to use
cond well Thomas Jefferson he always had
that in mind he did he and if you read
his letters in invisible link you see
those two then in 1972 Eisen stad V
bared they say okay actually we
discovered in the last seven years um
non-married couples also can use birth
control so somewhere in the Constitution
um if not for those two decisions and
the political opening up of birth
control would men and women have gone
nearly as crazy was it already baked in
or was that like the
driver well but then but then
of are we saying that that never it was
never legalized it was well in certain
communities or just not at that moment
just yeah basically it there were never
a national right to birth control or
like if birth control never existed is
that another way of well certainly if
birth control had never exist sure
that's the most extreme version of
it yeah I don't I don't think it'd be as
bad but it's a matter of degrees Yeah so
but it would what I mean question I
don't know what we're talking yeah we
were talking about filet of fish I think
uh yeah the drugs explain why so if it's
said like the one of the main drivers of
women craziness then I would say yes but
explain why it makes it sound like
that's the whole story I don't think
it's the whole St but it also I don't
want to just gloss because we're having
this more kind of legal and political
conversation but the drugs also make
women go crazy yeah I think right
hormonally and yes I I've SP this is not
just me what do I know I've never taken
the pill but women I've spoken to who
are on the pill for a long time and now
these girls go on it at 12 or something
yeah they will say they themselves will
say yeah I was nuts when I was on the
pill yeah and getting off the pill was
hard now you think condoms are gay but
now they you know how much gayer is
going to be a birth control pill for men
which they're working on they are
working on that could you imagine there
were men who I don't want like a a man
with one of those like pill you know
things he has to open up and take
his I was reading about there are guys
who are
20 yeah I'm not even I can't imagine
that at like of course how could you
yeah that's not not for me not for me
let's let's I'll say that but if you I I
at least can understand
the line of modern reasoning that lead
lead men to a certain
but 20 yeah what kind of a a
unic what is the world coming to what's
it coming to I would rather have an AI
babysit my kids than a
liberal uh um h
grudgingly correct yeah I'm G to say no
also it's a false choice because the a
both liberal are programmed Yeah by
liberals yeah so they're both liberal
and at least the yeah right the
liberal by virtue of Being Human might
have some unwitting tethering to reality
it might have like some semblance of a
soul left yes the AI is it's just demons
if it has a soul it's a demon soul right
yeah yeah
that's uh the flood story from the Bible
is a historical event the truth of which
is
suppressed by the scientific
Community
correct uh you got it wrong I would say
yes you would say okay good I don't I
was been cautious there on the I don't
know if the literal full like I don't
know if you were big lib on you know EXO
Jesus you think I'm like Episcopal yeah
going to a church with a rainbow you go
to the Priestess and you say hello
Bishop riss please give me a blessing um
well this is one where like the
the this on top of scripture the
scientific uh evidence is pretty strong
and we know that uh historically like
every ancient civilization as a flood
story yes and they're ALS and many of
them are quite similar which which is
often used as as a means to discredit
the biblical story but I've never quite
understood that to me it's like okay if
all of these ancient civilizations
agreed yeah not only on like that there
was a flood but also that uh oftentimes
that that some small group people were
saved from the flood yeah and how is
that supposed to discre to me that just
lends more credibility to this idea also
the fact that we we keep being told by
the modern Libs there have been these
major climactic events throughout all of
the ages and uh the
nature of the continents has changed and
Global mean temperature has changed and
there are these ice ages and this that
and the other thing asteroids hit the
earth it's so crazy to think there was a
big flood yeah there's there's good
scientific evidence for Sodom and
Gomorrah being destroyed by fire and
brimstone you're telling me there
couldn't have been a big flood now do
you think it was do you think it
necessarily had to be a flood that
covered the entire Globe
literally it would have had to
cover civilization certainly yeah like I
don't I don't think that that uh Mount
Everest was was underwater yeah I don't
I I suppose I'm agnostic on that I don't
it wouldn't bother me if at Mount
Everest were not covered but certainly
like when you mention the Other
civilizational Stories of the
floods I I got Gilgamesh pilled some
years ago and when I realize that that
story has a lot of similarities
to the Bible to to me I thought oh yeah
okay that makes sense
of course and even more distant
civilizations had the same story and
even and and you know those are
civilizations that are all kind of close
to each other but you go over to the new
world you know and and you find flood
stores there too which is very
interesting yeah yeah I totally agree
calling fans sweet
babies is more uncomfortable than a
podcaster calling fans creamy cream
puffs sweet baby there's more on
uncomfortable uh so you I know you're
wrong about this so this is one that
you're wrong throw a point up on the
board thank you very much I agree look I
you agree I I agree it's it's it's the
cream puffs thing is weirder I held off
on this thing
because the the sweet baby gang came
into existence in a very organic way it
did because you mentioned some talk show
host who you played a clip and then they
it was the
people who you don't know the origin I
don't okay so what happened how what is
the no we don't talk about but that's
not
it it's Monique but that we don't talk
about it Monique I would have said
moisha yeah no no it's Monique Monique
started the s b but we don't have that
conversation we don't talk about it it's
the first rule of the SPG yeah she's the
Godmother she doesn't even know it could
you imagine her Joy yeah on learning
that I think she would be
so then people wrote in after the SBG
sprang to life they said Michael you
need a you need a gang I said no guys
it's like a guy in high school giving
himself a nickname you can't you can't
you can't do it it's and they threw out
all these I'm not even going to say the
ideas because I don't want to embarrass
anyone to suggested them but they were
all so profoundly cringe and and I I
said no guys please no you can't you
can't do such a thing but
then something did happen at least
somewhat organically in a French Organic
way like a creme fresh almost I
mentioned I said okay jerem is making us
all do member block now so the member
block is not for the ho pooy it's not
for everybody it's for the crem laem
it's for the absolute tippy top you know
get to Cod of the member block and I
guess I said this enough that there was
this very pretentious idea that came
about
the like a little cream puff which I
thought guys they're
already saying my intro is gay
and now calling me a cream puff and
that's not I yeah so I I uh I've not
I've embraced it to a degree I it's
funny it's my favorite dessert is a
pereral I love a nice cream puff much as
I like a nice loer they're disgusting
what cream puffs I think of the right
thing yeah like a nice juicy little
flaky pastry with a nice little on the
inside with yeah
it's it's like a jelly it's like a
glorified jelly donut like a yeah like a
French and pretentious jelly donut with
no jelly it's just cream it's like a
Bavarian donut yeah so it's it's a jelly
donut except gayer is what you're saying
it's so gay and so I was like guys I I
know I told you don't do a contrived
thing but if the organic thing is going
to double down on the gay thing then I
don't this is kind of a net this might
be a net negative for me you should have
gone with like the Crusaders or
something but that's contrived that' be
like me being like hey my team is going
to be called the really cool handsome
guys like they can't it's not going to
yeah yeah just you let it you got to let
it happen but then sometimes it happens
then it happens and you wonder about it
yeah similar to the 2020 election Matt
Walsh's Mortal Kombat Showdown was
completely rigged with another gamer
playing for Matt what are you even aware
I no I I mean I
saw you you're obviously a very talented
video gamer okay so youve already
answered oh d i don't yeah I don't I
don't even understand look I
obviously I probably can't say this on a
certain social media
platform obviously understand the 2020
election was completely stolen by Joe
Biden and the Democrats and the
globalists but um but you don't but the
game was so clear yeah I don't know look
I don't I don't I don't personally
understand it
um but I guess I'm just a natural gamer
when it at heart yeah yeah what were
your favorite growing up what were your
favorite games um we never got so you're
younger than me right so
what my I was like the N64 generation
wait and my first games were like Super
Nintendo like Donkey Kong yeah no I
never had I'm saying N64 came I think
when I was like in fifth grade or
something and so all so and then
PlayStation then like so but I I only
ever had Super Nintendo so oh oh got it
okay yeah yeah when not so yeah I was
begging my parents for video game system
yeah and they wouldn't get it and then
and then finally N64 came out like right
before Christmas of whatever fifth grade
and um they said they're going to get me
the video game system and then I opened
it up and it was Super Nintendo so they
got me the one I I got the one that was
right behind and then I went to school
at you know I went to school after
Christmas break and everyone's talking
about they got N64 yeah and they said oh
did you get it and and I lied and I said
I said yeah you know in the moment I
just felt like I had to fit in it's one
of those moments yeah and then I had to
live in the lie for like the whole rest
of the year that I had N64 and they they
were all talking about Super Smash BRS
and you were like yeah yeah I I had no
idea what games they were talking about
and I just I was living this total lie I
was very traumatized you were playing
Donkey Kong Country right which is maybe
the best video game ever it's great I
enjoyed the the the playing it Minecraft
level was it's one of the great levels
ever the game which maybe maybe this
explains my hatred for video games is
like the trauma that I suffered as a
child your conservatism you were beh you
were one generation behind the
traditional Grace tradition wow did I
did I win no this do we have a
score they say we think you won by one
me that I won what we think you one by
one that's great I like that that's some
nice Philadelphia 2020 scoring is what I
know they got some pipes bursting in the
back over here uh Mr Walsh thank you
cheers we we actually drank a fair bit
on there usually I have like a sip or
two thank you
for purchasing this game at
dailywire.com
shop and for tuning in we'll see you
next
[Music]
time